Now what's coming up?
Um,
as I mentioned last week,
on Wednesday,
I'm going to give my censorship lecture.
And in preparation for that,
I would like you to go to a local bookstore,
anyone,
and just observe how it's laid out,
what you see.
Uh,
what's you,
what your attention is called to,
what your attention is not called to.
And here's a difficult question,
what isn't there.
Think about that and,
and I'll talk a little bit about what isn't there on Wednesday.
Also,
in order to keep up,
please try to read at least two,
page 202,
that's the next chapter,
division in the human stain so that you're on track to finish it.
It's 361 pages for next Monday.
And so next Monday,
a week from today,
I will give my second lecture on the human stain.
Now I will talk about the human stain a little bit on Wednesday because some of
what I have to say about censorship does pertain.
So that's what's coming up.
Okay.
I hope you all thought about the identity plot as you read this novel.
It's hard not to.
Um,
when I gave that lecture,
I suggested that when a genre gains a certain credence,
a certain widespread use in the culture,
it requires more and more innovations on it to make a fresh story out of it.
Um,
it also gets us to the point where that set of conventions is available to
writers in a new way to be transcended in a new way.
So one thing that I want to ask about this novel is does it transcend the genre?
Does it do more than provide the certain dramas and satisfactions that we come
to expect from a novel about identity in this sense?
Because it is so deeply embedded in those kinds of narratives.
Roth is taking a kind of risk here.
Yeah.
He's playing it safe because he knows that this is a topic of interest,
but he's taking a risk as an artist because he's working in very well trodden
territory.
I suggested that also when a genre reaches a certain point of saturation,
writers tend to change the subject.
I didn't say this when we talked about blood meridian,
but I think in part blood meridian is that kind of change of subject,
so this returns to the genre and we want to ask what it's doing with the genre.
Before I go into my meditation on that question today,
I just want to call your to another element that does relate back to blood
meridian and that's its status as a historical novel.
This novel places itself with certain kinds of historical markers at the very
opening was the summer of 1998 the summer of the Monica Lewinsky affair,
the summer when Viagra takes off in the marketplace.
Those are very contemporary historical markers.
Now think back to the way blood meridian opens with its historical markers.
Do you remember this line?
It's the father talking about the sun,
the kids birth.
He says night of your birth,
33 God,
how the stars did fall.
I think I've got that correct.
What he's talking about is the Leonid meteor showers in 1833 that mark the night
of the kids' birth for all that McCarthy is interested in and mining the
historical detail of the 1830s forties 50s
okay.
That novel favors historical markers that seem like cosmic markers of time,
so contrast the stars falling in.
Yes.
A historically specific meteor shower,
but nevertheless in something that looks like a cosmic communication of meaning.
Contrast that with the relatively mundane debased historical markers that Roth
chooses Viagra,
the Monica Lewinsky scandal.
Yeah.
You want to ask yourself what kind of history is each writer in woking?
I want to suggest to you that if you press on the markers that Roth chooses,
you will find something more than Trivia,
more than contemporary trivia that Roth has in his sights and equal universal
trans historical kind of truth in this novel that's brought up by those little
details of history
and that trans historical history is the history of desire.
Yeah.
Of which both those things are indicative.
I will say a lot more about desire and its relationship to the history of
literature and to writing.
In this novel in my Monday lecture.
But as you go on,
I would like you to think about how history functions as a set of context for
the story Roth Chels here.
Now I want to talk about identities.
So does this novel conform to the form of the identity plot?
There are certain ways I think it does and it does.
So in a very explicit way.
Remember how I mentioned that tension in the identity plot is produced by the
individual's relationship to the group and the way that's vexed,
it isn't a very exciting identity plot.
If the protagonist just discovers that he or she is whatever categorizable
identity it does,
oh good,
I'll be that.
And then goes on.
The tension comes from feeling that either such an identification would be
coercion or that it comes with all kinds of tended suffering.
There all kinds of tensions that are produced in making that I'm not an easy
identification and you can see that very explicitly in this novel.
On page one oh eight,
uh,
one oh six one oh eight when Coleman
talks about being at Howard University.
And along with that,
the experience of being called a nigger for the first time,
this is on the top of one oh six
especially when he began to think that there was something of the nigger about
him,
even to the kids in the dorm who had all sorts of new clothes and money in their
pockets and in the summertime,
didn't hang around the hot streets at home,
but went to camp and not voiced out scout camp out in the Jersey sticks,
but fancy places where they rode horses and played tennis and acted in plays.
What the hell was a cotillion?
We're was Highland beach.
What were these kids talking about?
He was among the very lightest of the light skinned and his freshman class
lighter,
even then his tea colored roommate,
but he could have been the blackest,
most benighted field hand for all.
They knew that he didn't.
He hated Howard from the day he arrived.
Within a week he hated Washington.
And so in early October when his father dropped dead serving dinner on the
Pennsylvania railroad dining car that was pulling out of 30th street station in
Philadelphia for Wilmington and Coleman went home for the funeral.
He told his mother he was finished with that college right there in that
sentence.
In this little set of scenes about Howard and his experience in DC,
you see him at first being asked by his family to identify with a certain
version of the black middle class and then finding he is revolted by his own
difference from that middle class.
He feels like a black field hand,
the darkest of the dark field hand for all.
They knew that he didn't and on one oh eight we get it in very abstract terms.
You finally leave home the earlier of we and you find another way,
another place that's just like that.
The substitute for that.
The problem of the identity plot is the problem of the eye in the wee.
Here's Coleman laying out exactly how he feels about that.
And so what he's going to favor their,
again,
on one oh eight is the Ra I
all the subtlety of being silky silk.
So there you have encapsulated in a very short amount of pros,
a major form,
narrative form,
narrative dynamic of the identity plot as a genre.
On one 44,
you get another version of that slightly a
more personalized to his family.
This is another version of identity and what Coleman thinks about it.
This is after we get the history of Coleman's family,
his ancestors,
and were told that he is not the first to pass as white
or to disappear from the black family into which he was born.
Um,
lost himself to all his people was another way they,
the family put it ancestor worship.
That's how Coleman put it.
Honoring the past was one thing,
the idolatry that his ancestor worship was something else.
The hell would that imprisonment.
So this version of identity on one 44,
this vision of it is identity as ancestor worship and imprisonment in that
family imprisonment.
In that way of thinking a radical unfreedom.
So this is one version of identity,
radically individual rising out of the difference that you feel from the various
we groups you are asked to join,
but there are other versions of identity that are imagined here and they track
pretty clearly with scholarly ways of thinking about identity at the same time.
So in one sense identity is this radical individual humanist version that I've
been tracing in the last few minutes.
Another is that identity is a constantly changing performance and we get that
too in Coleman,
you see it again,
right in this section about Howard on one oh nine
and I want you to note the words that
yeah,
Roth chooses here one or nine in the middle.
He could play his skin however he wanted color himself just as he chose,
play his skin any way he wanted.
Now remember that his father is a great devotee of Shakespeare and tries to
communicate to his children not only through their Shakespeare in middle names,
but through every verbal interaction he has with them,
that the grandeur of the English language will somehow fill them and make them
who they,
who they are.
That this is the source of their dignity and their power.
He takes that lesson and transforms it.
It's about playing on the model of drama,
but it's about playing color.
And this is an artist's vocation
color himself,
just as he chose.
He's like a painter in this sense.
So this is identity as performance.
There are many instances of this on page one 15,
one 16.
There's just a little,
um,
a little description of Steve.
Anna's dance for Coleman.
Yeah,
we're going to just read a little bit of it.
Okay.
All at once with no prompting from him,
seemingly prompted only by Eldridges trumpet,
she began with Coleman,
like to describe as the single most slithery dance ever performed by Fergus
falls.
Girl after a little more than a year in New York City,
she could've raised Gershwin himself from the grave with that dance.
And with the way she's saying the song prompted by a colored trumpet player
playing at like a black torch song there to see plain as day was all the power
of her whiteness,
that big white thing.
Someday he'll come along the man I love and he'll be big and strong.
The man I love,
the language was ordinary enough to have been lifted from the most innocent
first grade primer,
but when the record was over,
Stena put her up to hide her face,
half meaning half pretending to cover her shame.
Okay.
The history of jazz that's concentrated into that tiny little passage has been
unpacked by a critic by the name of Jonathan Freedman.
He does a whole history,
which I can't produce here,
um,
of how Ardi Shaw and various players played Gershwin,
and use black musicians in their ensembles and how this very dance when Stena
here we're told in a way in habits most fully her whiteness.
She does that by performing to a music that is radically hybrid black and
Jewish.
Okay.
So Friedman argues that in this passage we get identity as a vision of absolute
fluidity,
absolute performance and fluidity.
Okay.
And that the whole history of American jazz stands behind that imagined state.
It's the very difference between the hybrid music and the pure whiteness of
Stena his body that creates what's so provocative to Coleman,
the spectacle of whiteness in the context of hybridity.
Yeah.
The father's obsession with the English language though has taught Coleman to
categorize relentlessly.
Do you remember this little detail?
Um,
this is on page 93
when Coleman is describing or we're having described to us exactly how Kohlmans
father taught them to speak.
This is on 93 growing up.
They never said see the bow.
Wow.
They didn't even say see the doggy.
They said,
see the Doberman,
see the Beagle,
see the terrier.
They learned things,
had classifications.
They learned the power of naming precisely
the father for all that he is,
imbuing them with the most elite version of a white literary tradition.
Shakespeare.
He is also teaching them relentlessly to see classification and categorizing
in this comes to mean something quite different.
And you see it in this funny little passing moment on one oh seven
great.
It's very top of the page.
I'm just talking about his father's cherished volume of Shakespeare's plays,
the oversized book with the floppy leather binding that when Coleman was a small
boy,
always reminded him of a cocker spaniel.
The Seinfeld,
his father's majesty as never before the grand year of both his rise in his
fall.
The grander that as a college freshman away from barely a month,
blah,
blah blah.
And then it quotes from Shakespeare,
the Cocker Spaniel.
Why,
why choose that as what the little boy thinks of when he looks at that floppy
volume?
It's a moment when being trained to classify and to categorize causes him to see
the source of that linguistic precision.
The book of Shakespeare in very demeaning terms or reductive terms or I'm not
getting the quite the precise word I want,
um,
in deflating terms
so that instead of grandier the book of Shakespeare becomes the source for the
names of dogs.
And the way the child's imagination blends grandeur and the ordinary,
I think gives us Coleman who can imagine the details of everyday life,
the life he lives as a grand play.
Yeah.
Doc owner furthers this transformation of the father's lesson in this very
crucial passage that I'm going to talk more about later.
When Coleman passes as white or Jewish for the first time,
and that's when he's boxing for the pit coach.
If nothing comes up up,
doc said this is the bottom of 98 you don't bring it up.
You're neither one thing or the other.
You're silky silk.
That's enough.
That's the deal.
You're neither one thing or the other.
You're silky silk.
This takes the question of categorization.
Are you colored?
Are you not?
It negates it.
You're neither one thing nor another,
but then reinstates it in a different mode.
You're silky silk.
Make up a new category for yourself.
So doctors,
nurse takes that transgressing use of precision that we see in the Cocker
Spaniel Metaphor in the child's imagination,
and he shows Coleman how to apply that to living race in America,
living his race in America.
You're silky.
Silk,
you're not a race,
you're a proper name.
The irreducible singularity of a person.
There's a third way of thinking about race,
and that of course is as biology.
That two is present in this novel.
The body is relentlessly president.
I hope that you picked up on that.
It's not hard to pick up on it.
The very matter and specificity of the body is everywhere in this novel.
And so I want to look back at 21 and 22.
This is in that wonderful scene when Coleman dances with Nathan.
Nathan.
Yeah.
So we get a whole description of coalmines body and what it is that Nathan
season it suddenly now that he's shirtless on this hot summer night.
And also,
uh,
now that he is no longer talking about the spooks business.
Okay.
This is 21 on display where the shoulders,
arms,
and chest of a smallish man still trim and attractive,
uh,
belly no longer flat to be sure,
but nothing had gotten that had gotten seriously out of hand altogether.
The physique of someone who had seem to have been a cunning and Wiley competitor
at sports rather than an overpowering one and all this had previously been
concealed from me because he was always shirted and also because of his being
having been so drastically consumed by his rage.
What you see there is the revelation of certain things.
We will find out to be true about Coleman,
that he was a cunning and wildly competitor rather than an overpowering one,
that he is still fit and virile,
that he has himself in hand.
Nothing that had gotten totally,
that had gotten out of hand seriously out of hand.
Coleman very much still has himself in hand.
He is still the maker of himself,
the presenter himself to the world in in a deliberate way.
Yeah,
but then we go on and there are some things that we see that perhaps tell us
something different rather than the body revealing the truth about Coleman,
certain kinds of truth,
not a racial truth,
other kinds of truth.
We see marks on his body that don't produce that knowledge.
Also previously concealed was the small pop Irish Blue Tattoo situated at the
top of his right arm just at the cha shoulder joining the words u s navy
inscribed between the hook like arms of a shadowy little anchor and running
along the hypotenuse of the deltoid muscle.
A tiny symbol if one were needed of all the millions circumstances of the other
fellows life of that blizzard of details that constitute the confusion of a
human biography,
a tiny symbol to remind me why our understanding of people must always be at
best,
slightly wrong.
Okay.
What's revealed when Coleman is shirtless is the very sign that he cannot be
known in any kind of complete way.
It's the mark of a history on his body that he was in the navy.
Uh,
history we'll learn a little bit about,
but not a lot,
but for Nathan,
it is the mark of an irreducible difference between persons that always there
are details that are not accessible
circumstances of the other fellows life
in this moment.
Nathan recognizes Coleman as a cipher assign that can be projected upon with
meanings of his own.
I would suggest to you that we don't see the full flowering of this until quite
a bit later in the novel,
but I think this is the first moment where in Coleman revealing his body,
he suggests to Nathan the possibilities of that body as a sign.
Okay,
so he is no longer in this moment entirely in hand anymore.
So if his physique hasn't gotten out of hand,
his circulation as a sign certainly has in this case,
he has now become a blank canvas for Nathan.
Certainly up until this moment at the beginning of the novel,
what's most on the surface of the plot is how he has become the victim of rumor.
How his self presentation got completely out of hand,
taken over by other people's erroneous readings of his words.
So if the body seems to be in his control himself as a signifier is not here,
Nathan is invited into it,
but in a very different way than the rumor mongers who surround him at Athena
college and in the town.
So the body is not going to be a place of revelation.
Speech as I've noted is a problematic moment of revelation,
but it can be that.
And on 81 82 we see an example of that when his speech formally in the novel
touches off what will be some of the most important regulatory passages in the
novel.
And this was when Nelson primus having berated Coleman and advised him in his
clever,
authoritative,
arrogant way not to pursue anything against Leicester Farley or Delphine
[inaudible]
yeah.
Has offended him and enraged him so much as to become the target of coalmines
rage come said,
I never again want to hear that self admiring voice of yours or see your smug
fucking lily white face.
And the question becomes why.
And we see Nelson ask it the next page.
Why White?
Why does lily white become the insult that he hurls at Nelson
and formally,
even though there's a little bit of a,
um,
an interlude here about Athena college and Coleman's rage,
this is the moment when we launch into the tail of coalmines childhood and we
learned for the first time what kind of family he comes from and what the
history of his passing has been,
how he made that decision to abandon his family of birth.
So speech can be revealing,
but only in those moments when it is out of coalmines control here in this
moment,
lily white is inspired by his rage.
He's out of control in that sense.
And of course,
lily white is the term his brother Walt applies to him in a similar moment of
anger after Walt that he has told his mother that he is essentially estranging
himself permanently from the family in order to marry Iris.
Walt says,
don't ever show your lily white face,
uh,
here again.
So he's reproducing Walt's language.
And from that it indicates to Nelson,
Primus and for us in the unfolding of the novel that there's a mystery here to
be told.
And then we get the telling of that mystery.
So from that little word,
all of this unfurls
and I would know just in passing that this is quite a contrast to Delfin room
on 38 and 39 you can look at it.
Coleman is very surprised that she has made no effort to hide the identifying
marks of her own handwriting.
Delphine row though her name suggests the Delphic,
the ARAC color,
the mysterious.
The secret
Delphine is someone who cannot conceal herself the very material of her
language,
of her writing of her letters,
puts her identity on the page to be red.
And it seems as if she hasn't even tried to conceal it.
So Delphine's lack of depth,
her lack of complexity as a character.
Her basic despicable illness is summed up in that inability to conceal herself,
whereas Coleman only reveals himself in moments when he's unguarded or when he
has become not a person in control of his own representation of himself,
but rather a sign at large among other representers,
Nathan,
Delphine,
other people.
Secrecy then is at the very heart of what identity means in this novel.
And now I want to get to this crucial passage on page 100
for me.
This is where we learn really
what
identity means in this novel.
So he says he wants to be in this fight with,
um,
in front of the pit coach with Ray Robinson.
Okay.
It wasn't just that this is on 99,
it just the Coleman Wade some seven pounds more than when he'd boxed on the
Amateur Card at the knights of Pythius.
It was that something he could not even name made him want to be more damaging
than he'd ever dared before to do something more that day than merely when was
it?
Because the pit coach didn't know he was colored.
Could it be because who he really was was entirely his secret.
Okay.
He did love secrets.
The secret of nobody's knowing what was going on in your head,
thinking whatever you wanted to think,
with no way of anybody's knowing all the other kids were always blabbing about
themselves,
but that wasn't where the power was or the pleasure either.
The power and the pleasure,
where to be found in the opposite,
in being counter confessional in the same way you were a counter puncher and he
knew that with nobody having to tell him and without his having to think about
it.
That's why he liked shadowboxing and hitting the heavy bag for the secrecy of
And I'm going to skip down a little bit.
He talks about concentrating and how the secrecy,
um,
is produced by the concentration or is related to the concentration on the one
thing that you're doing.
Whatever's to be mastered.
He becomes that thing.
He could do that in biology and he could do it in the dash and he could do it in
boxing and not only did nothing external make any difference,
neither did anything internal.
That little example right there,
he could do it in biology on a biology exam.
He could focus exclusively on that thing,
become that thing in the dash in boxing in the ring.
But why choose that example?
Why not mathematics?
Why Not Chemistry?
Well here again,
it's Roths craft coming through.
Rauf chose that because what Coleman does is precisely to overcome biology.
It's the biology of who his parents are,
of who their parents are.
That biology,
the biology of American race
is what he takes hold of and transforms.
It becomes his secret.
Biology becomes his secret,
not as an academic subject,
but as a lived experience.
Boxing is the sport of concealment.
For him,
thinking ahead,
observing his opponent,
watching how slow the punches,
all the answers that you came up with in the ring you kept to yourself.
And when you let that the secret out,
you let it out through everything but your mouth for all Coleman's training in
the English language from his father,
his mode of revelation,
his mode of communication is not verbal.
Okay?
It is somehow physical as a physical performance,
as a damaging physical performance.
That term counter confessional being the pleasure and the power we're in being
counter confessional in the same way you were a counter puncher in not telling.
This is quite a remarkable term for Roth to use the history of Roths,
a writing from,
uh,
the very first story collection.
Goodbye Columbus,
uh,
published in 1960 through the many,
many novels in the next five decades.
That trajectory,
which I'm going to talk a little bit about on Wednesday,
is defined by the confessional quality of many of these works.
So Roth is widely known for drawing on his own life in his fiction and for
making Nathan Zuckerman track his biography in significant ways.
And in this novel it happens to be true that Philip Roth went through prostate
cancer surgery and now lives up in the Berkshires
and has been very secluded up there and very productive writing novels in the
last 10 years.
So in this novel already,
anybody who knows even those basic facts knows that Roth himself as a writer is
confessional in some sense of the word.
One question we might want to ask is,
is he counter confessional the way that Coleman is,
the way that you can be a counter puncher?
And what would it mean to be that?
Why does it matter
in fact,
does it matter?
And then why does it matter if it does that his novels track his life?
This is a longterm question for anyone who thinks about Roths writing,
and I will get more to it,
uh,
in my second lecture on the human stain next Monday.
But it's something to think about.
Yeah.
But let me pause again on that rhetorical question.
Was it because the pit coach didn't know he was colored?
Could it be because who he really was was entirely his secret.
There are two ways of reading that last question.
Who he really was,
was entirely his secret.
If we read that,
who he really was as a colored guy from east orange.
Yeah.
Then we'll see it as that being his secret.
But you can read it.
You can parse that grammar a different way.
Who he really was was his secret.
Okay.
Could it be because who he really was was his secret secrecy as the essence of
identity.
Doesn't matter what's in that hidden box doesn't mean that we have to fill it
in.
Doesn't mean even that it can be known.
And you think back to the way the anchor on his arm,
the Tattoo on his arm reminds Nathan of how little you can ever know about the
other fellow.
They're very fact of the person's otherness to you means that there is always
something fundamentally hidden about them and that arises from the simple
difference between one consciousness and another.
Yeah.
This returns the meditation on identity to a universalist humanist version of
what identity would be.
It's simply private consciousness.
Private consciousness is what defines us as persons
and then reading radiating out from that all the things that one can do with a
private consciousness,
which then encompasses these other modes of identifying that the novel rehearses
and then critiques or sometimes endorses plays with jumbles,
juggles
with a private consciousness.
You can decide to decide.
This is something that Coleman does on a number of occasions and it's a phrase
that Roth repeats when he's deciding to decide to be done with the spooks
business deciding to decide not to be worried about luster.
Farley.
Yeah.
You have the power to form yourself presentation.
You have the power to make your identity and artistic performance.
That's what private consciousness does for you.
But
it does a couple other things too,
and I want to track those or suggest them just briefly before I end today.
Um,
in one sense,
by following the theme of difference and in the other sense by following the
word secrecy in the novel,
first on the question of pure difference on 47
and that
wonderful scene of Fanya with the cows,
this is Nathan reflecting on the desire that he sees enacted there.
And again,
remember Coleman is not,
uh,
primarily a man of words,
but a man of being,
and he has just stood in silence with Nathan watching Fanya milk the cows.
Yeah.
It was enough to be able to conduct themselves like two people who had nothing
whatsoever in common.
All the while remembering how they could distill to an orgasmic essence,
everything about them that was irreconcilable,
the human discrepancies that produced all the power.
It was enough to feel the thrill of leading a double life.
And what this passage pass the sentences above emphasize is that Fanya is a
woman of 34,
a wordless illiterate.
And that Coleman is a man replete with the vocabularies have to ancient tongues
as well as his own native tongue.
So the very difference between them this time limbed in terms of education and
language,
vocabulary literacy here,
it's that difference that is invoked as the engine of desire.
So if desire is always that looking towards the other thing,
the thing that you are not,
the thing that you do not have,
the thing that is absent from you,
that's the definition of desire.
You can't have desire if you already have the thing desires that that force
that's always reaching towards something that is separate from you.
Difference between human beings is just that in this scene,
just the engine of desire.
So here for all the meditations on race,
the social construction of race,
racist performance,
racist essence,
racist biology,
race has secret.
It's secret that gets to that overarching concern with desire in the novel.
And this is a moment where I think Roth is transcending the genre.
He's taking the dramas of the identity plot and he's driving them to an extreme
and pushing them over into another subject matter.
So in this sense,
identity as secrecy pushes us over into the subject matter of desire and
mortality,
which is,
uh,
at the heart of Ross writing from beginning to end.
Now,
I will not say that identity is not also
a subject matter he's working with from beginning to end of his career.
That's definitely true and I'll say more about that on Wednesday when I talk
about the shape of his career,
but especially as Roth moves later in his career,
these questions of desire and mortality take the upper hand.
Now the last thing I want to do just very quickly is 0.2,
page 44 another use of that word secret,
very top of the page.
The secret to living in the rush of the world with a minimum of pain is to get
as many people as possible to string along with your delusions.
The trick of living alone up here,
away from all agitating entanglements and Luhrmann's and expectations apart,
especially from one zone intensity,
is to organize the silence to think of it's mountain top plentitude as capitol
silence,
as wealth,
exponentially increasing the encircling silence as your chosen source of
advantage and you're only intimate.
The trick is to find sustenance.
This is quoting Hawthorne again,
the communications of a solitary mind with itself.
The secret is to find sustenance in people like Hawthorne in the wisdom of the
brilliant deceased.
Now,
one question I myself as a reader have struggled with about this novel is
weather.
Nathan,
whether Roth imagines that Nathan state when he describes it that way,
is a false one or a week one one to be rejected.
Is it a withdrawal from life?
I think that last sentence,
the secret is to find sustenance in people like Hawthorne
gives us the answer that I'm content with and that is yes,
it's a withdrawal from life.
If you don't understand Hawthorne as a person,
as someone with whom you can become entangled,
it's the very act of thinking of a literary forebear as a person rather than a
text that allows this to be a productive state.
One that Nathan be drawn out of by Coleman,
but yet one that the novel does not reject.
Okay?
It's when Coleman becomes for Nathan a character,
the person becomes this living representation that he is drawn out of his
solitude.
So in a way,
it's not even Coleman,
the person that draws him out,
but his world when he encounters Coleman and his story,
when he sees Coleman's body during that dance as a cipher,
as the sign of all that you can't know about the other fellow,
when he sees that about Coleman,
that's when he comes out of one productive state of communing with the brilliant
dead and comes into the
world of Coleman,
who will be dead very,
very shortly.
Okay,
so on Monday next I will talk about that relationship between desire and the
literary between persons and characters,
between life and novel.
Think about those things as you read.